bonjour la politique ce n'est pas
seulement des chiffres des statistiques
des pourcentages des raisonnements ou
même des ambitions c'est aussi et
surtout comment vivent les gens or il y
a une question qui me touche
profondément c'est celle des personnes
âgéés nos anciens qui vivent à la fois
parmi nous et si peu parmi nous aussi
ai-je demandé à Louise gerbé ouvrière
retraitée qui vient du rô exactement de
vie urbane et à Véronique Niobé médecin
généraliste dans la banlieue parisienne
d'évoquer ce problème avec nous et c'est
encore Roger Louis qui animera ce débat
avec moi et bien est-ce que je peux peut
commencer par vous demander votre âge
Louise je vais avoir 71
ans vous avez travaillé toute votre vie
j'ai travaillé toute ma vie à l'âge de
13 ans j'ai commencé à travailler
actuellement je suis retrait
par la Sécurité
Sociale j'ai une retraite
de enfin on m'a accordé une retraite de
160000 anciens francs par trimestre en
1975 comme je suis veuve j'ai demandé la
reversion de veuve on m'a accordé 60000
anciens francs par
trimestre ce qui me fait 220000 anciens
francs par trimestre de retraite et
comment peut-on vivre avec ça et oui
alors comme je ne peux pas vivre avec ce
petit salaire
j'ai fait un emploi j'ai pris un emploi
je suis gardienne dans un
immeuble et avec la paye de gardienne et
mon salaire de retraité ça me double ça
me fait une paye valable vous ne pouriez
pas vivre décemment sans sans continu à
TR sans travailler je ne pourrais pas
vivre ce serait pas possible ce serait
impensable mais enfin quand même depuis
7 ans je crois que le gouvernement dit
qu'il a accordé pas mal de de de moyens
supplémentaires nonou oui quelques
petites augmentations de 2 % 3 % tous
les ans 6 et demi % cette année enfin
tous les ans il y a une petite
majoration mais de toute façon ça ne
fait pas des des grosses sommes tout ça
puis il y a aussi le petit impôt qu'on
fait payer sur les retraites
ou le prélèvement le prélèvement alors
tout ça c'est pas bien ça ne fait pas
des grosses retraites non plus c'est
bien dur à vivre et puis ce serait bien
mieux si on donnait en augmentant
d'abord les retraites et ensuite en
donnant une retraite mensuellement au
lieu de la donner triémestriellement ce
serait plus favorable pour les petit
retraités mais quelles sont vos vos
préoccupations maintenant à l'âge de
vous avez atteint dans dans ma fois
préoccupation c'est d'abord de conserver
une bonne santé pour pouvoir continuer
mon emploi et puis d'avoir de voir
autour de moi mes enfants en pleine
santé aussi mes petits enfants également
et surtout de ne pas les voir clients au
chômage et aux maisons intérimaires
comme depuis 2 3 ans ça s passé chez
nous c'estàd vous estimez que le travail
pour les jeunes puis moi si je pouvais
être payé un peu plus par la Sécurité
sociale par ma retraite et bien ma faut
je laisser facilement ma place à une
autre personne Franois mitteran quand le
gouvernement dit nous avons fait un
effort considérable pour améliorer le
sort des gens âgés est-ce que on peut
aller plus loin est-ce que sans
démagogie est-ce que c'est compatible
avec les possibilités économiques je ne
dis pas qu'on est rien fait je pense
qu'on n pas fait assez et lorsqu'on
m'oppose que cela n'est pas compatible
avec les moyens de la France je dis que
ce n'est pas exact bien entendu si l'on
veut pouvoir répondre aux besoins des
personnes âgées il faut changer de
politique comme dans beaucoup d'autres
domaines et c'est la politique que je
préconise l'autre politique qui tente à
relancer l'économie et surtout à mettre
tout ce que l'on peut mettre dans la
lutte contre le chômage qui nous
permettra d'y arriver mais puisque vous
avez parlé de de problèmes précis je
voudrais tout de suite y répondre sans
m'attarder plus qu'il ne faut justement
dans les chiffres que je dénonçais tout
à l'heure car le problème des personnes
âgées c'est aussi vous le savez bien un
problème de dignité vous avez parlé de
la pension de reversion je pense qu'il
faudrait que par étape successive mais
rapide on puisse passer de la pension de
reversion de 50 % à 60 % bien sûr ce
sera ce serait déjà pour beaucoup de
gens qui n'ont pas grandchose je crois
que vous en es un exemple un moyen de
s'en tirer mieux vous avez aussi parlé
de du prélèvement sur la retraite 1 %
sur le régime général et 2 % sur les
régimes complémentaire c'est une mesure
qui a été prise contre tous les
engagements du candidat sortant qui en
1974 avait promis précisément de ne pas
frapper les retraites enfin cela a été
fait je pense qu'il faudrait ir sur
cette décision mais si l'on veut encore
seenir à ce sujet je voudrais vous dire
que le minimum vs c'est 1416 francs par
mois j'ai dit qu'il faudrait le faire
passer dès le mois de juin prochain à 17
à 1700 francs par mois et à 2000 francs
dès le 1er janvier
1982 vous savez tout cela le chiffre
actuel ne représente que 53 et5i % du
SMIC 53 et5 %. quand on dit que on a
beaucoup fait modérons aussit notre
jugement et je pense qu'au cours du
prochain SEPA on devrait pouvoir aller
jusqu'à 80 % du SMIC il y a d'autres
problèmes bien entendu il y a la
revalorisation des rendes viagères il y
a surtout je parlais de dignité tout à
l'heure au fond l'idée que l'on se fait
de la façon dont devrait vivre ou
pourrait vivre les personnes âgées dans
notre société on bâtit des maisons de
retraite moi je l' fait à châau Chinon
là où je suis maire je crois que j'ai
bien fait car il faut bien penser au
person personnes valides au personnes
invalides qui trouvent un toit et qui
peuvent s'organiser dans de bonnes
conditions mais il vaudrait mieux sans
doute que les personnes âgées puissent
vivre chez elles dans les maisons
qu'elles aiment dans leur environnement
auprès de leur voisinage mais pour cela
naturellement c'est pas possible s'il
n'y a pas les aides ménagures les aides
soignantes il n'y a pas des personnes
des travailleurs sociaux qui iront à
domicile et qui pourront s'occuper de la
santé des soins du ménage tout tas de
choses qui feront que la personne âgée
se sentira au fond bien avec nous et se
sentira comment dirais-je dans la
dernière partie de sa vie entouré
d'affection et de soin c'est sur ce
point que je me permettrai d'insister
parce que
augmenter les allocations c'est bien
c'est nécessaire pensez à la dignité des
personnes âgées qui ont accompli leur
vie qui ont servi la société et qui ont
souvent des enfants c'est votre cas et
des petits enfants dont il faut assurer
l'avenir je crois que c'est leur rendre
justice tout
simplement Véronique vous êtes en tant
que médecin amè amener à avoir une
vision peut-être plus globale dans la
banlieue parisienne là o vous travaillez
non ce problème oui je travaille dans la
région parisienne et je suis surtout
amené à voir des gens qui sont âgés et
mais qui sont malades et je voudrais
dire que ce sont des gens qui ont
travaillé beaucoup dans leur vie dans
des conditions souvent difficile et ce
sont ceux-là souvent qui sont le plus
touchés par la maladie et ce n'est pas
souvent avec que Louise a l'avantage
d'être en bonne santé elle arrive à
vivre avec ce qu'elle gagne or les gens
que je vois sont souvent des gens qui
non seulement ont déjà peu pour vivre
mais qui en plus sont des gens qui sont
malades et qui sont isolés par leur
maladie et par le fait aussi qu'ils ont
des des revenus très peu très peu
importants mais est-ce que le problème
se
pose exclusivement en termees
financiers non le problème ne se pose
pas évidemment seulement terme
financiers il se pose aussi en terme
social et puis de chaleur affective et
familiale mais c'est vrai que une aide
ménagère à domicile favorise le
rétablissement d'une personne qui est
grabataire c'est vrai que aussi 3/4 des
personnes âgées qui pourraient
bénéficier des aides ménagères n'en
bénéficient pas parce qu'il n'y a pas
assez d' ménagère à domicile est-ce que
vous avez des exemples de conditions
financières
global qui amène finalement une
situation je vois beaucoup de gens qui
vivent avec uniquement le le minimum
vieillesse c'estàd 1416 francs par mois
et quand on sait que les le la santé
coûte cher puisque ceux qui soi-disant
sont pris en charge à 100 % par la
Sécurité sociale depuis 1 an doivent
payer 80 francs par mois en plus si leur
leur traitement coûte moins de 400
francs par mois c'est donc déjà une
erreur et de dire qu'elles sont prises
en charge à 100 % d'autre part les gens
âgés c'est vrai utilisent des
médicaments pour leur santé et ces
médicaments coûtent de plus en plus cher
et les médicaments dit de confort ne
sont plus remboursés par la Sécurité
sociale ou sont remboursés seulement à
40 % les gens âgés aussi utilisent ces
médicaments il n'y a pas de raison de
les pénaliser de cette façon Françis mit
vis poser une dernière
question on dit souvent que les gens
âgés vote de façon conservative vote à
droite si vous voulez en général est-ce
que c'est une des raisons qui vous amène
à réaliser une émission à leur
propos
mon mon rôle et ma mission c'est
d'essayer de convaincre la majorité des
Français quelle que soit la catégorie à
laquelle ils appartiennent que le
candidat des socialistes que je suis que
la gauche c'est celle qui a conquis les
droits à travers le 19e et le 20e siècle
c'est la gauche ce sont les travailleurs
leurs organisations ce sont ceux qui ont
représenté soit sur le plan politique
soit sur le plan syndical les masses les
travailleurs ce sont ces gens-là qui ont
conquis les droits alors au fond la
société actuelle et les dirigeants de
cette société il considèr par exemple
les les aides ou les allocations aux
personnes âgées comme une charité et moi
je veux reprenant la grande Histoire de
la gauche je veux en faire un droit un
véritable droit le droit des personnes
âgées à vivre dans notre société je l'ai
dit tout à l'heure non seulement avec
des allocations correctes des moyens de
vivre correct mais aussi dans une
certaine ambiance de solidarité
nationale et j'y tiens beaucoup parce
que j'entends souvent dire ici et là ce
sont des bruits qui rasent les murs que
en effet les personnes âgées votent à
droite parce qu'elles craignent que la
gauche que les socialistes leur enlèv
les pauvres les pauvres acquis de leur
vie ce qui a été le le le résultat de
leur travail c'est c'est au dieeu
d'entendre cela car j'entends pendant
les 7 années qui vienent consacrer
l'essentiel de ma tâche à rendre justice
aux françaises et aux Français qui
vivent difficilement alors qu'ils
méritent davantage à ceux qui produisent
à ceux qui travaillent à ceux qui à la
fin de leur vie ayant produit et
travaillé se trouve dans une situation
diminuée ça c'est la just
c'est le droit dont j'ai parlé et c'est
mon devoir que de veiller à ces
choses